and now here's an effort trying to help
latino law students here in the valley
break into the legal field yeah they're
having a thing called the undelay 5k
it's a fundraiser thousands of dollars
in scholarships to help local kids pay
for law school admission test prep
courses because those are not cheap are
hector mejia live at sunset park uh
you've been following the group that's
training and hector we're waiting to see
you get on the jogging course out there
too
well yeah you know i've i've been trying
to catch up we have been following them
but they are just outpacing me here we
are
getting ready training this morning
stretching and we're going to say andale
because this is all about the underlying
5k joining us live we have marissa
rodriguez founder who's going to talk to
us about the big mission big goal tell
us all about it good morning hi good
morning hector thank you so much for
having us here uh the andale 5k is save
race to we fund raise up scholarship
funds for latinos who are aspiring to go
to law school tell us how it's different
this year it had to be virtual last year
for obvious reasons this year we're all
getting together when september 18th and
participants have two options you can
either sign up to do it virtually from
the comfort of your your neighborhood or
you can join us at casey sports complex
on buffalo in washington on september
18th at 8 a.m and people can register at
andale5k.com and this is all to help
local students
scholarships already given out for a
number of students
yes
we focus mostly on nevada-based
attorneys however the scholarship is
open to latinos nationwide
in the past two years we've already been
able to grant 57 scholarships and we are
very happy to report that some of our
scholarship recipients have already been
admitted to a number of law schools and
how expensive are those courses to
prepare yourself to make it to law
school it's close to two thousand
dollars with the preparation course and
the actual uh law school entrance
admissions test uh it's close to two
thousand dollars which can be very
expensive for college students
and it's still really active out here
you know they've been running we want to
also introduce monique rodriguez who is
a scholarship recipient from last year
she's going to talk to us how it's
helping her good morning good morning so
tell us how the scholarship is helping
you get through school all right so i
knew that i wanted to take the lsat to
go to law school but a big barrier was
getting the materials to study paying
for the tests paying for the reports
so i was that was another thing adding
to the stress of the year right 2020 was
not the most fun never
but uh when i got that scholarship i was
like all right now i you know i can move
forward with what i want to do i was
able to study with um of course like an
online instructor which was amazing
especially considering i was going to
use like free resources before
and there's not many of that for the
lsat
so i'm really glad
it was key to me getting my scholarship
awesome thank you very much and
congratulations to you you are going
where unlv uh boys school of law
congratulations all right so we'll be
posting all of the details all the
information on our website
eightnewsnow.com
it happens on september the 18th eight
o'clock in the morning for now we're
going to send it back over to you guys i
have to join them i kind of followed
them earlier but i wasn't able to catch
up but gotta let you guys go for now
reporting live hector mkhitaryan eight
news now back to you guys it's about
time hector been waiting for you to get
down the get on track there so uh enjoy
the 5k and get your heart moving there
appreciate